ADDISON HOWARD:
Well, hello everyone
and welcome to today's
Google Cloud Next Session
during Cloud AI Week.
My name is Addison, and I'm
joined by my colleague Phil.
We're both members of the
Kaggle competitions team,
and we're excited to
speak with you today,
specifically about TPUs
and TensorFlow on Kaggle.
But first, what's Kaggle?
Historically, Kaggle's
become synonymous
with machine learning
competitions,
but it's really much,
much more than that.
Kaggle is a data
science platform.
Over five million
data scientists
from all over the world
come to Kaggle not only
to participate in the machine
learning competitions,
but to learn data science,
build their skills,
polished their portfolios,
and share data sets and code.
It's truly an incredibly
exciting community.
Now my job at Kaggle is to run
machine learning competitions,
and they run the gamut.
Right now we have 17
competitions running,
ranging from understanding
bird sounds, [INAUDIBLE] lung
function decline, classifying
melanoma, NLP challenges,
and even a
bot-building simulation
competition, among many others.
We recently wrapped up a
competition with a $1 million
prize that detected
deep-fakes in videos.
We had a competition recently
with both the NCAA and the NFL.
And even abstract
reasoning challenge
with Francois Chollet.
And by the way, if you haven't
seen his recent paper titled,
On the Measure of Intelligence,
I mean, it's pretty amazing.
Really encourage you check
that out after this session.
But basically, if you're
interested in data or machine
learning in any form
or fashion, we've
likely got a competition
that will excite you.
And really, one of the most
exciting elements of Kaggle
is that as the home of data
science, professionals,
hobbyists, thought
leaders, and academics
will come to Kaggle to test
new theories, technologies,
and potential advancements in
the state of the art of machine
learning.
Now we've been very
fortunate to witness
the birth, or the spread
and dissemination,
of many of the leading
data science techniques,
from back when
random [INAUDIBLE]
decision trees took over, to
LightGBMs, XGBoost, and then
the introduction of
libraries, like Harris.
So what better community to
introduce great technologies,
like TensorFlow and TPUs, than
through Kaggle competitions.
And the Kaggle community is
filled with data scientists who
are eager to
experiment and quickly
uncover the benefits
and shortcomings
of newly-introduced
products and methodologies.
And a Kaggle
competition that can
provide a structured
and engaging format
to test them out.
And specifically for
TPUs and TensorFlow,
our competition platform allows
us to host really large data
sets, and to offer both time
and resource-constrained formats
that can help truly
capture the power
and understand the benefits
of these particular tools.
So if you'd like to check out,
the latest TensorFlow edition,
we're calling it 2.x,
as they continue to be
updated on the Kaggle platform.
Especially with GPU or
TPU, Kaggle makes it easy.
You can see from the
list on this slide
that we've eliminated
a lot of the obstacles
to making TensorFlow 2.x build
your models fast, with next
to no specialized coding.
No provisioning of the
right kind of VM, no setup.
We already have data sets
that are ready to go.
Our cloud notebook
platform removes the burden
of needing to reconcile versions
or libraries or packages
across collaborators, so sharing
and iterating is a breeze.
And finally, we even
provide a weekly allotment
to TPU and GPU time at
no cost to our users
all over the world.
And the integration benefits
afforded to TensorFlow
also apply to TPUs.
They're directly accessible
from archival notebooks
that [INAUDIBLE]
additional setup.
We have generous
data sets that are
accessible via Google
Cloud Storage that allow
for efficient data access.
30 hours of TPU use per week
are granted to each user.
We've even hosted
five competitions just
in the last six months aimed
at these particular tools.
Most recently, we
hosted a competition
that was TPU-centric with
the Google Team, Jigsaw, that
was seeking to
evaluate and classify
toxic comments on Wikipedia.
We also just launched
a competition
called Contradictory,
my dear Watson, which
seeks to use TPUs
and natural language
processing to evaluate grammar.
But today we want
to look specifically
at our first two competitions
that introduced TPUs to over
five million data scientists.
First being TensorFlow
2.0 Question Answering,
the second being one on
flower classification.
Now TensorFlow is
already very heavily used
in our competitions.
It's currently being used in
all of our running competitions,
but in the past
few months, we've
run two TensorFlow
competitions that I mentioned,
this one on top being a question
answering NLP competition built
around the launch
TensorFlow 2.0,
and a new competition
for image classification
that introduced TPUs for the
first time to our platform.
We already have
tens of thousands
of people using TensorFlow 2.x
right now to solve problems.
And three of the top solutions
in the question answering
competition ended up
using TensorFlow and TPUs.
And so next what I want
to do is, let's dive
in to some of the code.
Let's look at some
of the code right now
we'll build a model on Kaggle
for our competition that
classify flowers on CPU,
GPU, and TPU with no changes.
So Phil, I'm going to
hand it over to you
to walk through some of the
[INAUDIBLE] competitions.
PHIL CULLITON: Thanks, Addison.
We start off simple by importing
TensorFlow 2 and the Kaggle
data sets library.
The rest of the code
here does a bit of magic.
It figures out what
kind of accelerator
is attached to your VM, and
allows us to automatically
parallelize your model build.
This will determine an
appropriate strategy,
whether you're using a V3
TPU, or a simple CPU VM.
Basically, this code asks for
a TPU, and if it gets one,
it connects to it
and sets it up.
If it can't get a TPU,
it sets it up as well.
The rest of the
code in these slides
is entirely
accelerator agnostic.
Normally, outside
of Kaggle and Colab,
you'd need to provision
this TPU for usage
and do some other setup.
But on our platform,
that's not necessary.
Just select the TPU
from a dropdown and go.
Now we load up our
competition data set.
It's provided and sharded TF
record format for fast loading.
We use multiple files
to provide enough data
streams to maximize
the TPU's throughput.
First, we get the path
to those TF record files
and pass it to TensorFlow,
then set some parameters
for a training and
validation sets.
Shuffling our
training set, batching
both sets for
optimal performance,
setting our training set to
repeat so it'll loop back
around with the [INAUDIBLE].
We'll pass these into
our model and TensorFlow
will access these
TF record files
while the model is building.
The end result of
this process is
that we have data
sets ready to run
in our accelerator of choice.
This code does
some heavy lifting.
Here, we load up VGG16 for
some transfer learning,
and then define
our model by adding
the global average pooling and
output layer on top of that.
Note the with
strategy.scope block.
That's basically saying,
hey, whichever type
of acceleration strategy
you're using here,
this is the process
to parallelize.
Now our model will be
compiled and trained
on the accelerator we've chosen.
Note again that this same code
will run on CPU, GPU, or TPU.
As long as we identify
our distribution strategy,
TensorFlow 2
automatically handles
putting this model in the
right place and building.
After this, we compile our model
with our choice of optimizer
and loss, pass the training
and validation sets
from the previous slide
into it, and start
the model-fitting process.
Making some flower predictions
is easy after this.
We load up our test data set
using the same type of code
that we used to load the
training validation sets.
Once again, this
results in data that
makes the best use of our TPU.
Then we run model.predict,
transform our prediction
into the right form, and write
our predictions out in a format
that Kaggle can read.
With a few tweaks and
a few more epochs,
this model can actually
score pretty well.
I'll finish the code section
with some of the fun flowers
that our model has
made predictions on.
You can see that some are
right, they've got a little OK
above them, and some are wrong.
If you're interested,
you're more than
welcome to drop by the Petals
to the Metal competition
and beat these results.
That won't be hard, but
it will probably be fun.
And now, Addison, back to you.
ADDISON HOWARD: Thanks, Phil.
As Phil demonstrated in his code
review, using TPUs on Kaggle,
it's a super easy way
to get used to TPUs.
In the flower competition--
flower classification
competition that
Phil highlighted--
we had over 24,000 TPU-using
sessions by Kaggle users,
and a very small amount needed
any amount of help to get
started.
Thanks to some
getting-started work
done by some members
of team, over 80% users
needed no help to
begin using TPUs.
As you can see in the screenshot
of top Kaggle notebooks
in the flower
classification competition,
users quickly created and shared
their own TPU-based notebooks
and began to train each
other with discussion topics
and highly upvoted notebooks.
Many of these top notebooks
came from Kaggle's highest
ranked grandmaster users,
and it's really exciting
to see the data science
community very quickly
learning themselves so they
can then quickly teach others.
So let's highlight some
very specific outcomes
of this competition.
In the Kaggle
notebook, users can
elect to use a CPU, GPU, or
a TPU, like Phil mentioned.
So we picked two of the
top-performing models using
each TPUs and GPUs that each to
use effectively the same code.
The TPU model trained on
25,000 images in an hour and 15
minutes, and that same model
would run out of memory when
they try to flip it over GPUs.
The comparative GPU
model took five hours
to train those
same 25,000 images,
but they had to be
at a reduced size.
In the end, the accuracy
still did prove competitive
with the TPU model.
Now, prior to this
competition, there
had been some slight
murmurings of TPUs,
but once the first competition
was launched in February
of this year, you can see
the large jump in discussion
forward mentions per month about
TPUs, and it continued to rise.
Now as we introduce more
competitions, including
a competition designed
to help introduce TPUs
to the uninitiated,
we're looking forward
to seeing how not
just discussion
of TPUs and TensorFlow in
the community increase,
but how the data science
community continues to find
great insights in their spread.
So if you're interested in
seeing TensorFlow 2 at work
on Kaggle, come check it out.
Try out the code that
Phil just showed you,
compete in the
flower competition,
or try it out with the
data set of your choice.
Or try [INAUDIBLE]
past competitions
or on our hosted
notebook platform
where we give you some
TPU hours play with.
In the coming months,
we'll be launching
even more competitions
so you can
leverage power TensorFlow
and TPUs on Kaggle.
Now it's been a
big group effort.
I want to give a special
thanks to Martin Gorner, who
is the DevRel project
manager who led the effort
to integrate TPUs, so thanks so
much to him for his hard work.
It's pretty awesome to see how
easy it is to use TensorFlow
and Kaggle right now.
So finally, thanks
to you for joining us
with our session today.
Thank you for your time.
Please come visit
us over at the Dory.
We'll be hanging out
all week answering
any questions you may have about
TPUs in TensorFlow on Kaggle.
And again, thanks so much.
Have a great day.